los palestinos conmemoran Hoy 15 de mayo
El Aniversario número 75 de la Nava que
en árabe significa catástrofe es una
fecha en la que recuerdan el día en el
que más de 700.000 personas fueron
expulsadas de sus tierras tras la
creación del estado de Israel un evento
que dio lugar a una crisis humanitaria y
atenciones que se extienden al día de
hoy en medio de una nueva y reciente
escalada bélica entre el ejército
israelí y los militantes palestinos para
analizar este tema saludamos a Karen
marrón ella es corresponsal en medio
oriente y África del Norte analista
también en geopolítica especializada en
conflictos armados y derecho
internacional humanitario Karen gracias
por acompañarnos teniendo en cuenta la
situación actual y las dimensiones
también que han adquirido el conflicto
entre Israel y los palestinos Usted cree
que ha evolucionado de alguna forma el
concepto de magma y también las
narrativas a su alrededor
tal como decías María Clara significa
catástrofe fue la catástrofe que
sufrieron esos setecientos cincuenta mil
palestinos expulsados
y también la Nava Es un término que se
utiliza después de 75 años no solamente
como un suceso histórico lamentable y
terrible para cada uno de esos 750,000
palestinos que lo han vivenciado sino
para las generaciones porque tenemos que
sumar a esos 750.000 palestinos
expulsados y a los millones de
palestinos que se calculan entre siete y
nueve millones que en este momento
siguen teniendo el mismo estatus
absolutamente
lamentable y con temas humanitarios muy
complejos tanto el Líbano como en
Jordania como en Siria que tienen la
atención de la agencia de Naciones
Unidas para los refugiados palestinos
evolucionado Este término En qué ahora
muchos grupos
políticos palestinos y muchos palestinos
en sí
recuerdan la Nava como un hecho
histórico como un suceso fundamental
pero hablan de El aura o Laura es el
retorno se basan fundamentalmente en el
derecho al retorno que esto lo ha
implementado en muchísimas resoluciones
no ha emitido la asamblea general de
Naciones Unidas Entonces sí hubo una
evolución desde la Nagua hasta la el
aula el derecho al retorno pasando por
otros como han sido la parte y la
limpieza étnica Entonces sí podemos
hablar inclusive de un posicionamiento
político de muchos grupos porque este
esta nagba En algunos momentos en
algunas negociaciones se dejaba de lado
y al dejar de lado el hecho de la
catástrofe de los refugiados se estaba
dejando de lado el derecho al retorno y
esto ha vuelto al escenario político ha
vuelto a las decisiones de los
palestinos tanto
en los campos de refugiados como en el
exilio en diferentes países Usted cree
que hoy por hoy hay una narva actual con
la ocupación de los territorios
palestinos que es el planteamiento
palestino
sigue habiendo una catástrofe porque
desde hace 75 años
hay una
decisión por parte del Estado de Israel
por eso se habla en su momento y eso se
ha visto inclusive en hechos políticos
muy recientes de la parte pero el
término aparte reitero se basa también
en el derecho y también en las
declaraciones de la comunidad
internacional cuando tiene que ver con
cuestiones de diferenciación o
discriminación por etnia o por religión
es considerado a parte por lo tanto esta
nagba continúa pero reitero que se han
tomado posiciones cuando el derecho al
retorno María clara que está avalado por
Naciones Unidas tanto en su resolución
de 1947 la 194 como las Perdón del 48
como la ciento ochenta uno de 1947 y
creo que es importante nombrar estas
resoluciones Y estos años porque
estamos avalando esto con el derecho y
con las decisiones de la comunidad
internacional
si se nombra en forma permanente el
derecho al retorno y además la
restitución de la propiedad o de aquello
que ha sido dañado para la persona
expulsada de su territorio Entonces se
está volviendo la nueva continúa pero se
está al no ver sí que el no se puede
llegar a la solución de los dos estados
y a una paz justa duradera y permanente
en medio oriente Entonces el derecho al
retorno está adquiriendo protagonismo y
reitero pasado en lo que está
implementado por la comunidad
internacional que se ratificó ciento
diez veces en cincuenta años el derecho
al retorno Naciones Unidas María Clara y
hablemos precisamente de esa postura de
la comunidad internacional porque sea
resistido a reconocer el nagba a pesar
de los 75 años y del vínculo que usted
plantea tan interesante en el
reconocimiento de la Nagua también es un
reconocimiento al derecho al retorno
porque esta reticencia a reconocer la
Napa
precisamente porque se reconoce la narva
hay una postura del estado de Israel en
vamos al al mismo punto está el derecho
al retorno
repetido con suetudinariamente por la
comunidad internacional
pero Israel también con
suetudinariamente manifiesta que no va
ese es un tema que no se trata y no se
ha tratado en el en muchos en muchas
situaciones donde se intentaron
implementar acuerdos de paz entonces
inclusive hubo discusiones dentro de de
intra Palestina dentro de los políticos
palestinos porque si no se tocaba ese
tema ese es un tema fundamental reitero
personal y colectivo y e imprescriptible
Entonces no se habla de la nada porque
el estado de Israel dice que eso es
imposible
al ser eso imposible dificulta que se
produzca esta Paz
y esta justicia y está restablecimiento
basado siempre en el derecho
internacional y en el derecho
internacional humanitario por lo tanto
tenemos que ver
cuál es el camino hacia una paz en un
conflicto que ya se considera un
conflicto permanente teniendo en cuenta
estos 75 años Karen gracias por
acompañarnos y por explicarnos todo esto
Muchísimas gracias María Clara ustedes
sigan conectados con nosotros Porque
continuamos con las noticias
internacionales
[Música]